[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler alexis
paulin et horia liste rt france bonsoir
alexis à vos côtés me crever
l'éditorialiste politique vous venez
eric revel de publier fenêtre de tir la
présidentielle 2022 et le grand retour
de l'ordre aux éditions ring merci
d'être avec nous ce soir avec nous pour
nous accompagner également l'éclairage
de l'entrepreneur et observateurs
politiques que vous êtes également denis
jacquet bonsoir
réindustraliser pays pour devenir une
grande nation d'innovation ce sont les
mots donc des manuels mettront ce matin
qui a détaillé avec précision ses
ambitions industrielles pour un deuxième
quinquennat même s'il ne le dit pas
encore un plan de 30 milliards d'euros
d'investissements
regardez emmanuel macron qui dit donc
vouloir produire deux millions de
véhicules électriques et hybrides en
france notamment d'ici 2030
c'est ambitieux de se positionner pour
2030 alors qu'on n'est même pas encore
en 2022 l expo là c'est un peu ridicule
et j'ai envie de dire à quoi sert
françois bayrou il est commissaire au
plan c'est lui qui est sûr c'est faire
un peu ces planifications alors on
apprend dans un livre aussi que
apparemment bamako aurait payé bayrou
pour qui le soutiennent là il fait ce
qu'il aurait dû faire lorsqu'ils
arrivent au pouvoir le problème des
modèles macron c'est que pendant des
années tout sa formation son logiciel
politique idéologique s'il en est un
c'est d'être dans la fusion dans
l'intégration européenne dans la
mondialisation et de vendre les bijoux
de famille d'avoir des industries et la
france de faire de la france un pays de
services est aujourd'hui le découvre à
cause ou grâce à la crise du coc vide
que on est totalement mises à nues quand
une crise arrive et qu'on ne produit
plus sur le sol national on perd des
emplois et que c'est impossible alors il
a beau jeu aujourd'hui de dire qu'il
varie industralisés de payer alors qu'il
a passé sa carrière finalement à des
industriels pointent le pirate ali par
exemple
c'est quand même le père le président de
la start up née sean qui étaient là pour
de porter sur un nuage hubert et ne dire
que des lointains sur l'ubs et risation
l'économie et là il se rend compte que
non une économie sans industrie ça ne
fonctionne pas alors tant mieux qu'ils
ne s'en rendent compte maintenant le
seul problème c'est que on voit bien que
c'est dans un timing de campagne
politique et combien va nous coûter
aujourd'hui la campagne des manuels
macron voilà ça se chiffre en milliards
mais tout ça c'est des promesses et
c'est uniquement pour son image
d'ailleurs ils se réservent voyez il est
sur scène comme sur un thé dicks c'est
vraiment le télévangéliste qui est là
pour dire je suis génial je vous promet
des milliards on vous promet il ya une
prise de conscience soudaine des manuels
macron c'est vrai que même avant d'être
président le miz de l'économie avait
démantelé certains fleurons des
entreprises françaises prise de
conscience sincérité ou fins
électoralistes comme qui aimerait quand
même ça c'est un fait qu'on peut
vérifier s'il n'y a jamais eu autant de
fusions acquisitions et de bradage de
certaines entreprises françaises que
lorsque emmanuel macron et ministre des
finances ça c'est un point certains ce
que j'aimerais dire quand même et je
regardais vos titres tout à l'heure
c'est que start up start up nation le
guen je veux dire c'est le problème à
mon avis des manuels macron c'est qu'à
mon sens quand on est présentement
république et c'est l'un des sujets de
mon livre on doit incarner la fonction
on ne doit pas considérer le pays comme
une start up on doit considérer le pays
comme une nation avec tout ce qu'on doit
protéger à l'intérieur d'une nation doit
rassembler on doit pas diviser on doit
mettre du baume sur les crises et non
pas donner l'impression qu'on est con
aviv les plaies pour moi j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui que emmanuel
macron poursuit dans cette dans cette
voie là c'est à dire il y gère un peu la
france comme il gérait une grande
entreprise ce qu'il finira peut-être par
faire s'il est battu en 2022 et et je
pense que c'est pas le rôle du président
un public alors maintenant à l'excision
la raison
quand vous êtes en pré campagne il faut
dire si vous faites le calcul depuis
quinze jours trois semaines de tout ce
qui a été promis aux différentes
corporations
en france vous allez voir que la
calculette nice à faire camélia voilà on
sait même pas d'ailleurs exactement
comment on va payer tout ça on a une
dette de 2 min
22 ni écouté avec intérêt je mets des
comptes ont justement donné jacquet vous
l'entrepreneur qui avait beaucoup fait
causer aux états unis quand même il y
avait une nécessité
on va pas rentrer dans le détail
effectivement de deux discours m'enfin
bon les semi conducteurs qu'on
produisait parent france y'a quand même
cette prise de conscience à la faveur
justement de la pandémie c'est salutaire
ou vous êtes aussi sévère causé dollar
sur le plateau
ayant appris à connaître alexis j'étais
pas surpris mais je suis ravi de
retrouver votre autre ami aussi on s'est
pas parlé depuis très longtemps donc moi
je suis toujours aux états unis
maintenant j'y vis définitivement
écoutez le
c'est quand même dommage d'attendre
quatre ans et presque et demi avant de
s'apercevoir qu'il était bon d'avoir de
l'ambition pour la france on se demande
pourquoi on en a pas eu depuis le début
d'autant qu'on sait qu'une année pèse
une éternité aujourd'hui en matière
technologique 6 heures quand vous perdez
8 - vous avez perdu huit ans donc
certainement le gouvernement
il ya quand même eu une vie avant le pot
vide donc du coup c'est vrai que pour
tous ceux qui avaient suivi un peu
macron dont je faisais partie à
l'origine on avait tous pensé qu'une des
premières dispositions les ambitions de
la france très justement d'en avoir une
et on a été très déçu parce que un an
deux ans rien bon une année 2000 que
vides c'est clair mais donc un la
première chose je pense que c'est alors
vous pourrez dire c'est mieux vaut tard
que jamais mais néanmoins aujourd'hui
elle s'en apercevoir juste avant les
élections c'est quand même un petit peu
c'est quand même un petit peu borderline
mais c'est le jeu des politiques
habituels à la projection la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de 1
comment dire d'euros maquillage de
mesures déjà existantes donc c'est pas
30 vrai nouveau milliards c'est des
trucs rafistolé du plan de relance qu'on
nous a promis que jamais venue du plan
de réindustrialisation qu'on nous a
promis par le vide à peu près tous les
jours et dont on attend toujours le
début d'un bain d'un exercice et puis
surtout je voudrais rappeler enfin dans
mon précédent bouquin sur la chine
pourquoi votre prochain patron sera
chinois et d'ailleurs il m'a encore être
lavé plus rapidement avec des ambitions
aussi petit c'est que assez étrangement
la dixième ville chinoise en 2019 avait
investi sur l'intelligence artificielle
seulement juste là dessus 10 milliards
d'euros vous imaginez une seule ville la
dixième de chine 10 milliards d'euros
donc 30 milliards c'est beaucoup c'est
l'argent des français on sait pas d'où
il sort puisqu'on en a plus donc en fait
encore de l'argent qu'on va
vraisemblablement inventé mais surtout
si on veut une ambition si l'ambition
européenne d'abord elle pas uniquement
française parce que là le jeu
aujourd'hui les acteurs sont mondiaux
ils sont pas français donc il faut aller
se battre contre la chine et les états
unis et c'est pas avec 30 milliards on
va aller les chercher et c'est sur cinq
ans cr 6 milliards par an mais qu'est ce
que vous faites avec similaire sais même
pas ce qu'a dépensé sur un seul sujet
une seule ville chinoise en une année
donc je pense que là c'est assez
ridicule dans le montant alors du coup
c'est pas le contre-pied exactement de
ce que disait alexis jean françois c
c'est juste qu'en réalité cet argent-là
part il est re maquiller et si tenté que
ce soit une bonne idée il est totalement
je dire l'échelle aujourd'hui
d'investissement on le sait pour être
dans les secteurs d'avenir c'est une
centaine de milliards et donc ça vous le
trouvez pas en france et c'est pas sur
cinq ans c'est pendant tous les ans
pendant cinq ans et au niveau de
l'europe le spatial dans lequel on prend
un retard considérable donc je pense que
et le dernier point que j'ajouterai on
l'a vu avec le plan de relance et alexis
et j'en reçois qui observe çà depuis a
longtemps c'est qui va recevoir cet
argent ou va-t-il être allé par qui va
être administré et distribué parce que
je peux vous dire qu'il n'ya pas de chef
d'entreprise la question de la
gouvernance
on en reparlera si on a le temps et eric
revel alors bruno le maire m défend
évidemment
30 et midi ce soir la ministre de
l'économie que ça va créer 45 milliards
de de richesses et des dizaines de dans
points vraiment
[Musique]
ça créera forcément un peu l'emploi mais
je pense que on est plus à l'échelle ho
oui d'une certaine manière la
comparaison que vient de faire des nids
jaked est très importante parce que et
vous montre dans le quel état est la
france aujourd'hui et son économie
s'apercevoir qu'on a désindustrialisé au
nom de la mondialisation heureuse
pendant des années des années ce pays et
s'en apercevoir six mois avant
l'élection présidentielle s'est déjà à
mon sens une faute
non mais attendez attendez ça date pas
des menus mâcon mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est qu'on est plus du tout à
l'échelle la comparaison que faisait
denis à l'instant elle est très
significative on parle du déclin de la
france vous le mesurer également sur ces
chiffres les revers qu'on vient de subir
c'est une façon pour le présent l'appui
de reprendre la main on vous annonce des
chiffres ronflants on n'a pas les
comparaisons montech
c'est les deux regardez ce qui s'est
passé en australie avec les sous marins
regarder comment la france est traitée à
l'extérieur sur la sphère de la
réduction des visas pour les pays du
maghreb on a vraiment l'impression
pardonnez moi l'expression
et c'est par appeler un mauvais épisode
emmanuel macron mais qu'on se prend des
claques tous les jours si vous voulez on
se prend des claques tous les jours
c'est à dire que c'est l'argent qui est
mis sur la table à des fins
électoralistes n'est pas à l'échelle de
ce qui se passe dans le monde et
notamment du développement de
l'intelligence artificielle ou parler
denis est ce que c'est un combat perdu
d'avancé
dans cette affaire mais on joue pas du
tout à forces égales on est dans un âge
d empire américain chinois russes aussi
qui implose depuis des années nous
l'europe on est incapable de s'organiser
c'est extrêmement compliqué on est
toujours dans une compétition larvée
avec même si on est en train de dire
qu'on va travailler ensemble on voit
bien que les pays européens sont dans la
compétition et n'ont pas les mêmes
intérêts c'est là tout le problème aussi
la construction peine avec en plus les
registres mans qui a rendu encore plus
compliqué des projets d'envergure donc
on est incapable de faire des projets
industriels regardez sur arianespace ça
coûte plus cher maintenant que ce p 6
alors que on avait des années d'avant
donc on doit se poser la question à la
fois de ses moteurs la de la recherche
pourquoi on est incapable en france de
payer nos chercheurs pourquoi on les
forme très bien et pourquoi ils s'en
vont tout de suite on ne paye pas donc
il va des filières alors c'est ce qui a
été dit aujourd'hui par un résidant dans
celles qui est quand même un français
font dominer pdg de moderna qui est
parti aux états unis et qui dit on n'a
pas été capable en france de garder nos
deux ingénieurs et et non chercheurs il
est là le problème en pouvoir
indépendant bien sûr bien sûr eric revel
sur les sur la sphère de leblanc celle
moderna c'est un sujet très intéressant
ce qu'on vous l'interrogez il vous dit
quoi il vous dit qu'en france en fait il
aurait eu le capital humain pour
développer et modern art mais il n'y
aurait eu ni le soutien financier public
ni le soutien financier privé c'est ça
qui est incroyable parce que toutes ces
aventures puisqu'on parle beaucoup de
vaccins et principes actifs à cause de
la crise sanitaire sont des aventures
industrielles qui sont nés la plupart du
temps avec des start up justement donc
le président de la république mais oui
mais justement justement c'est là c'est
là où on a un problème c'est que on vous
fait des grand-messes comme celle ci
pour vous expliquer qu'on va déverser
des milliards d'euros et on avait des
startups en france à nantes qui à cake
qui a servi à développer un vaccin qui
était utilisé en grande bretagne on a
des start up qu'on n'aide pas con qu'on
regarde à peine et en même temps on a un
outil qu'ils aient localisent en
permanence souvenez-vous toutes ces
grandes marques industrielles qu'on a
paumé pechiney qui se souvient de
pechiney aujourd'hui mais quand pechiney
été rachetée pechiney c'était l'un des
fleurons industriels français ça a été
racheté la marque a disparu c'est la
même chose en l'aidant dans deux dents
dans d'autres secteurs où on a perdu des
fêtes la liste des entreprises mondiales
françaises qui ont disparu vous allez
voir que c'est absolument frappant et en
fait on ne cesse d 1,10 m en france c
est une qui note un peu comme un patron
de start-up justement or c'est le
président de la république c'est pas à
lui de faire ce discours il est devant
des patrons pour dire on va aider les
patrons donc en france on parle beaucoup
macron parle beaucoup il ce met en scène
comme un patron de start up mais c'est
pas ça qui va faire que ça marche donc
la réalité c'est que sur cette scène là
devaient se succéder des patrons qui
aurait dit qu'elle était leur succès on
a vu ça lors du sommet bpi un peu mais
mais clairement il est là dans une mise
en scène encore une fois de pour son
électorat pour dire je vais envoyer on
parle d'emploi on parle de création
d'investissement d'emploi pour les
années à venir mais ce qui intéresse
aujourd'hui les gens c'est quoi c'est
leur perte de pouvoir d'achat quand vous
regardez ce qui se passe sur le prix
d'énergie mais vous voyez vous ayez le
président de la république fait une
intervention pour dire dans x années
vous allez avoir des emplois et 45
milliards d'euros de valeur ajoutée dit
bruno le maire mais ce qui intéresse les
français au quotidien c'est de savoir
comment ils vont payer aussi leur
facture d'électricité justement il a
parlé du nucléaire il semble miser
beaucoup sur le nucléaire avec notamment
voilà le nucléaire de petite taille
denis jacquet 2
vu des états unis ça vous semble
séduisant on va s'en sortir grâce à ce
genre de de l'initiative du président
non mais je pense que là et eric l'a
bien rappelé alexis aussi c'est le
problème des chaînes c'est pourquoi la
france ne peut pas être à l'échelle de
la chine des états unis l'europe le
pourrait donc mais regardez la
difficulté avec laquelle pour un christ
decaux vide ils ont accouché d'une
mesure de relance de combien 600 700
milliards il a fallu des mois des
semaines de négociations ce qui revenait
à quelques dizaines de milliards par
pays et cet argent c'est toujours
d'ailleurs pour la plupart pas où il est
donc du coup comme on n'a pas un
alignement ne peut pas avoir d' europe
on ne peut pas être à l'échelle donc
tout ça pour moi c'est pour ça que
j'essaye de rester sereins dans le débat
et de ne pas être trop dogmatique mais
très honnêtement le timing de
l'opération le niveau qu'il est en train
d'afficher et les mesures qui à
l'intérieur quand on sait qu'après ça
passe par des ministères des régions une
administration technocratique et que cet
argent en fait on le verra véritablement
jamais pour bruno lo mèr promettre de la
valeur ajoutée des emplois franchement
c'est on est en ça frise la malhonnêteté
donc peut-être que oui enfin moi je suis
né en normandie peut-être ben qu'oui
ptêt ben qu'non mais j'aurais quand même
tendance à dire plus tôt peut-être ben
qu'non mais en tout cas pas à ce niveau
là donc et aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
plus de sujets qu'on devrait traiter qui
vont vous savez la valeur c'est simple
ça va de la recherche fondamentale au
fait de denfert des entreprises et qui
deviennent mondiale maintenant que vous
avez pas une recherche fondamentale qui
est bien payé donc vous avez pas
décloisonner la recherche et le business
tant que vous donnez pas des moyens non
pas c'est pas une start up née shon dont
on a besoin on a besoin de leaders
mondiaux c'est pas des start up de cinq
personnes avec 2 millions d'euros dont
on a besoin cette boîte qui font des
centaines voire des milliards de chiffre
d'affaires et qui partent à la conquête
du monde où on n'a pas cet état d'esprit
on n'a pas cette vision que l'éclairage
tout de même qu'ils sont les et les
florentins va pas si mal en france mais
qui néanmoins on vit sur nos acquis de
lvmh s'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais je
veux dire or je cherchais où est le
moteur de recherche le plus utilisé au
monde où est le et réseaux sociaux les
plus utilisés au monde enfin regarder
toutes les grands services digitaux les
plus utilisés au monde malheureusement
ils ne sont ni en europe ni ne sont
absolument pas et notamment pas français
donc on a su faire on pourrait savoir
parce que la france est un magnifique
pays avec des gens fantastiques
malheureusement ils n'ont pas les
dirigeants qu'il mérite alors on va
aborder une autre question politique
opposition évidemment qui dénonce des
fins électoralistes justement on y est
presque 1 dans six mois on va jeter un
petit coup d'oeil on sait d'âge ifop du
jour d'hier plutôt sur les intentions de
vote des français regardez l élection
présidentielle en avril prochain xavier
bertrand est au coude à coude avec
marine le pen talonné de très près par
eric zemmour qui ne s'est toujours pas
déclaré on le rappelle clairement les
kia deux candidats en dynamique et
l'eczéma ou xavier bertrand
emmanuel macron louis il est plutôt
confort pour l'instant encore et
toujours aimé le maquereau comme eric
zemmour n'est pas déclaré candidat il va
se déclarer le plus tard possible
puisque là il fait campagne sans faire
campagne c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
facile pour ce qui est de xavier
bertrand ça se complique puisqu'il a
accepté de participer au congrès des
républicains sans reprendre sa carte du
parti sachant que là il va se soumettre
au vote qu'il va pas être le seul et à
valérie pécresse qui aimeraient aussi y
aller et puis il ya le grand absent de
ce débat legrand silencieux on va dire
laurent wauquiez et qui pèse encore un
au sein du parti pour qui va-t-il aller
l'or en ce moment on parle d'un wauquiez
qui ils iraient derrière barnier et ça
pourrait totalement changer la donne de
ce congrès donc aujourd'hui on fait des
sondages sur de l'air puisque le congrès
n'a pas eu lieu puisque des candidats ne
sont pas encore déclarés enfin c'est une
présidentielle c'est un marathon il ne
fait que commencer on voit bien que sur
les ne dépareillerait qui prennent de
l'avancé mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils
vont aller au finish et souvent
d'ailleurs les sondages d'octobre le
gagnant était crevé le pari risqué la
pouvoir xavier père 36 noms alors
plusieurs choses quand même quand vous
regardez un peu les sondages des
campagnes présidentielles précédentes au
moins deux observations la première
c'est que un président sortant qui est à
24 25 dans les sondages c'est
extrêmement bas en réalité c'est
extrêmement bas parce que dès l'instant
qu'un président en fonction se déclare
en général il perd 3,4 points donc si
vous enlevez cette marche là vous êtes
dans un étiage de 18 19 points
potentiels pour emmanuel macron ça veut
dire que s'il ya pléthore de candidats
notamment à gauche dire que la barre du
second tour tête est à 16 17 18 points
donc tout le monde donne évidemment
emmanuel macron au second tour pour
l'instant il faudra voir ce qui va se
passer je ne dis pas qu'il n'y sera pas
je dis que 24 ou 25 % d'intentions de
vote pour un présent un public certes en
avant qu'il se déclare de nouveaux
candidats c'est pas un score si elle
veut que sa deuxième chose est sûre
xavier bertrand bond les sondages
montrent que ce serait le seul à pouvoir
peut-être battre emmanuel macron je
remarque une chose c'est que il ya
quelques semaines xavier bertrand a
expliqué qu'il n'y aurait qu'un candidat
chez les républicains ça veut donc dire
que il savait que d'une façon ou d'une
autre il devrait passer sous les
fourches caudines d'une primaire qui l'a
refusée avec son parti a ouverte a
finalement refusé ou d'un congrès moi ce
que je pense mais c'est vrai que
l'attelage wauquiez michel barnier peut
monter en puissance que je pense quand
même c'est que dès l'instant où il va y
avoir ce congrès la pire des choses pour
les républicains me semble-t-il c'est
que ce soit une sorte de foire
d'empoigné que le résultat ne soit pas
clair et net vous savez où vous souvenez
peut-être lors de l'élection d'un
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
mon cher alexis poulain ça mettait aux
prises deux dames madame martine aubry
et madame ségolène royal je me souviens
en début de soirée madame ségolène royal
avait quelques milliers d'oies davance
et au petit matin quand on s'est
réveillé madame martine aubry a dû
gagner avec 190 voix d'avancé et les
2000 premiers donc sous les ja je ne dis
pas que tout ça n'est pas transparent je
dis simplement que la pire des choses
pour un congrès des républicains s'ils
veulent mettre en orbite un candidat
c'est qu'ils soient élus de manière
claire nette et précise et que les
autres candidats peut-être potentiel
négocié avec celui ou celle qui peut
gagner des places dans un futur attelage
si c'est pour avoir une cacophonie
totale il vaut mieux personne ne se
présente pour les républicains et que le
congrès du 4 décembre
ils passent directement aux 24 pour
fêter noël ni jacques et je sais que
vous êtes un fin observateur de la
politique française également depuis les
etats unis eric revel le disait un
candidat à droite et le plus vite
possible comme le souhaite sa vie
bertrand parce qu'on a vu toute cette
voie la ccc petit rebondissement avec ce
phénomène médiatique ou pas on en
débattra une autre fois mais mme eric
zemmour qui est quand même venu mettre
un petit peu un coup pied dans cette
fourmilière et et changer un peu la
donne
moi je trouve ça très intéressant
d'avoir un outsider parce que je suis
entrepreneur j'aime l'indépendance n'est
la liberté de parole d'esprit et
d'action et donc le fait d'avoir je dis
pas eric zemmour mais un candidat comme
eric zemmour je pense ne peut faire que
du bien à la campagne parce que sur des
sujets clés il va être les autres vont
être obligés de se positionner et
d'avancer enfin des choses concrètes sur
des sujets qui de toute façon préoccupe
véritablement elle pas seulement les
français vous dire que c'est un sujet
dans tellement de pays du monde
aujourd'hui le restreint la france a un
peu limité je pense que les républicains
ont un problème c'est qu'en fait ils ont
malheureusement pas cette fois là un
candidat à la hauteur de la tâche pour
que moi je trouve que bertrand est très
bien dans la région nord pécresse s'est
fait plutôt du bon boulot un cd
candidats qui sont des très bons
régionaux comme il ya des régionaux de
l'étape dans le tour de france mais ils
ont pas le disons c'est pas un sarko
c'est pas il manque un truc quoi donc
barnier on est tellement en phase ou
bien si on commence à donner les clés de
la france à quelqu'un qui a eu les clefs
de l'europe dont on connaît le succès ça
me fait plutôt peur qu'autre chose même
si le personnage en lui-même pas
désirable donc en fait ils n'ont pas un
candidat à la hauteur c'est ça qui leur
manquent et puis la dernière chose ce
qui manquerait à cette campagne c'est
une femme neigeux d'hier une vraie phase
par exemple une christine lagarde ou
quelqu'un comme ça à quelqu'un qui est
vraiment internationale qui a une vision
du monde qui sait ce qui s'y passe capal
nombre y concentrer sur la france et qui
sait que les enjeux sont internationaux
aujourd'hui sont globaux et qui serait
le gérer avec une vraie bienveillance
donc je pense que cette campagne donc
beaucoup de féminisation comme toutes
les campagnes d'avant et malheureusement
peut-être encore celle d'après merci en
tout cas donné jacques et eric revel
merci beaucoup de votre présente annexe
me poulin et c'est la fin de cette m